have you seen the show strange
addiction' we've talked about it a bit
before and the clips everything that
they do goes viral because they get
clips of people that like to eat toilet
paper there was a woman who I think was
in love with her couch then we saw this
one which I thought was kind of
interesting this is about female maskers
okay you have to put in a lot of powder
so you don't stick to it and this is why
I do it over the bathtub so it doesn't
make a big mess in my bathroom you look
amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
that's why I do this because I think so
too
I just can't believe that that's a 70
year old man in the mirror and that's
why I do this if I saw a 70 year old man
in the mirror I quit this tomorrow what
do you see when you look in the mirror
not very exciting female if I were to
see a regular woman like this
and she would say come on let's hang out
I'd say okay let's go hang out this just
blows my hair back that I can do this
that's be in there that's that's one of
the things I have to keep telling myself
that's not just a 70 year old man and
that's me inside that female okay so if
you aren't exactly clear what a female
master is at this point I'll give you
the exact definition it is men who like
to wear rubber and silicone body suits
to resemble life-size shapely female
dolls look guys dress like women that's
sort of accepted at this point it used
to be like sort of a big joke I guess
but that's kind of accepted so is this
just the the next step of that I mean
it's I don't know like is it equally as
like kink or is it just lifestyle
it sounds pretty sexual videos like this
bros my hair back yeah there's a 70 year
old man and I'm inside that woman I just
think okay it's not my king yeah but
he's not hurting anyone and he's getting
fulfillment why not I know so when I was
looking at this story and when the
producer sent it to me I was kind of
thinking that sort of what I was
thinking like everyone's into weird [ __ ]
people do all kinds of stuff so this
guy's doing this and yes it's really
bizarre and it also feels like Silence
of the Lambs doesn't it feel like
Buffalo Bill yeah that's what he was
trying to do right he was trying to
build he's a serial killer of that right
like he was trying to build a woman suit
to put around his body
yeah so I don't so again I don't want it
now I'm comparing him to a fictitious
serial murderer so I don't quite yet but
like if this guy's not hurting anyone is
it is it bad to make fun of this then
because it's obvious like there's
obviously something funny
Brett clean it up my crazy fetish is to
tell jokes about things yeah and so I'm
going to tell jokes about this because
that's my kink it's not sexual really
but it's something I get a lot of
pleasure out
so he can't really attack me for doing
that yeah that's how that's me being
[ __ ] up so you wear your lady clothes
and that will make fun of it I think I
think he's that I would make fun of it
if he wasn't so gorgeous yeah that's the
thing that's what gets me is I there's
nowhere to go with this well-said right
error like how did we find out about
these people before reality TV so that's
the part that's the part that I think is
fascinating like this guy could be your
next-door neighbor right he could you
know work at the same place you work and
you wouldn't tell us I'm working on it
all right but really like these people
are there everybody right like we don't
know you know like this could be anybody
this guy now I really kept yeah I feel
like you really think I'm doing that
that's why the producer sent me this no
but what I think is fascinating like to
me like something like that there would
be a shame involved in it like you know
like you're weird kink whatever gets you
off like there's a weird shame but yet
these people are doing it on reality TV
so there's something about reality TV
here also that that's kind of
interesting
I accept drag and I accept furries this
isn't crazily far off from either of
those yeah can you explain what furries
are to the people who wear fur suits
it's not always necessarily sexual
sometimes it's like well I feel more
like I'm a fox and I'm more comfortable
I feel more in my own skin when I'm
wearing this fur suit yes there is sex
involved but it's I'm fine with it
yeah no no there's parts of it it felt
very gratifying go to search for maroon5
stuffed animals parents we're gonna
annotate right above your head right now
awesome just start waving for a second
it's right on Brett right there there
you go yeah anyway all right well that's
all I have to say about this it wasn't
anything groundbreaking I just think
it's kind of its kind of interesting and
you have something well I was I was
thinking is in building on what you were
talking about about before reality TV
you do find out about this to be
shocking and there'd be there'd be
shaming involved I think that knowing
that reality TV telling us that there
are people like this out there with
weird kinks makes it less likely that
when someone does find out about it
anything physically
harmful will happen to them so that's
interesting so is that the ultimate
redeeming thing of reality TV which I've
relentlessly and mercilessly mock and we
did a story last week about how nobody's
watching reality TV anymore and that's
actually great but is that sort of the
the good thing about it that it is sort
of exposing these things and then people
will be more okay with weird [ __ ] right
now we cuz we used to see something
different and we're afraid of it and we
kill it
now we see something different and it's
hilarious that we watch it and I think
for the people who are different that's
at least a better thing than being
killed right how great would it have
been if you had been in a silicon suit
this whole time and right now to end
this and just like I'm a 70 year old
[Music]